hey everybody and welcome to the Shan
method I'm Sean McGinnis back you're
back Sean this is maximal mcgee and in
fact I am back I spent two weeks out of
the country on my honeymoon not playing
any video games and it was wonderful but
also a little bit scary an old classic
an old favorite going to jump back into
GTA 5 we did have a suggestion for
something to do in GTA 5 today okay
which is try to steal an aircraft of
some type and fly it as low to the
ground as you can and try to high five
people try to high five people with your
wing all right maybe I'm sure they'll
understand outside this guy surely you
can talk them no more star wanted level
okay straight to the top go on time of
the good stuff oh I'm already maybe the
cow cab company cab company I need you
to drive me to the military base yep
where is the cab come on have I'm
getting antsy don't make me stab stuff I
got an edgy stabbing finger getting
stabbed you're kicking it make me stab
this truck get your staff and you kicked
on this job yeah it's gonna take cab cab
did he drive off Oh get this guy gives
this guy get this could take him down
now he's still going still going
freaking out a little bit though we got
a runner we got a girl a runner oh he's
down he's down we're good we're good
don't even sweat it don't don't even
sweat it no witnesses wash it from me oh
wow oh street justice Oh beyond the grid
all I did was murder that guy aren't you
taking that there sweetheart you're done
you're done you're done all right wow
it's amazing how quickly we've deviated
from the original plan which was to
steal an airplane just immediately low
fly buzzer people
yes guys didn't know well [ __ ] all right
taking a tumble all right it's a
shortcut no werth [ __ ] where's he
gonna go no no no there you go yeah here
you go catch my drift see you later
buddy no witnesses look now he's
breaking into the mill tape no witnesses
sorry soldier men all right here we go
that's what I motion that is at any time
motion thing about tanks is that they
can't catch you if you're driving in
serpentine motion what oh I got out too
far from the get pointer join get in get
in get in before you go through all the
appropriate stop officers all right here
we go take it off here we go Oh am I
gonna make this oh come on give this
little boost there's a little extra ramp
that we can go off all right all right
yeah what's up you written real broad
Boulevard this one right here Sunset
Boulevard oh god this is real okay all
right here we go oh here we go go go
coming in for a landing there's my
landing gear down okay he's okay here we
go here we go maybe I should just land
ah
you played chicken with one there you go
under the overpass oh wow sturdiest road
sign Oh somebody suggesting if you get a
tow truck you can abduct people while
they're in their cars oh that's a good
one should i reenact speed there's a
bomb on the bus you could you could put
a bomb on the bus there's a bomb on the
bus mom on the bus we can't slow down
well I think you have to get okay now
there's two moms on about look how
casually I'm doing this yeah the guys
looking yet I like him man hell is this
thing he's putting on my bus oh now he's
good now he's wise it up what's she
going come back here we go and I just
wanted to get my bus right I gotta get
downtown to get to my work come on back
you forgot one back I figure with the UH
the ignite the bomb button is I think
it's like left turn swimming to the bomb
button is Oh give your bus if you do
with these Parsons a lot of driving bus
you want to get last thing I mean it hit
in the tow truck we're doing where I was
oh yeah come on [ __ ] oh wow okay all
right okay we're gonna okay we're drug
emergency services here we go 911 for a
tow truck please amen what he's not it's
are like tow truck okay I'm not at all
I'm gonna hop into this cap hot pills
he's gonna take me there cab I need you
to know okay okay well punch him in the
face all right things got real hot real
fast things got real hot this escalate
in the big one cement truck Oh even
better even no no no don't get
distracted don't get distracted from the
task at hand whoa
here we go here we go we're gonna do
we're gonna clear out this situation see
you gentlemen kablammo eat it all right
we're good we are good we're not your go
maybe I'm doing I feel like I need to
give back to the community no he's the
man I feel like I need to drive a bus or
tow some cars around oh no no no get
away okay cowabunga okay okay okay for
we don't very easily distract you can
just give it a Baria we're gonna go to
arias find anybody while you're waiting
for the cab all right wait peacefully
okay for the cab you arrived okay I'm
gonna go to the small town so that we
definitely do find a tow truck I feel
like oh yeah here's gonna see I'm
learning I'm gonna better I'm improving
as a human being a what oh wait I like
it you gotta find this [ __ ] because
what is this [ __ ] just suggested
that you should make a tow truck
centipede Oh tow truck human centipede
even tow truck Santa Fe humans do not
need to be involved in the centipede sir
excuse me gentlemen mr gentleman yeah
whatever man do you know your selfie
where I might oh thanks good oh come on
John come back we'll get a selfie
together I need you to get no way no
wait wait wait wait now I'm getting
distracted you might find the tocho beat
yourself to death all right good find a
we're just getting a minor for this
perhaps Leverson your inner wait oh all
right there where does toe charts right
there's tow truck beautiful getting that
tow truck we're good all right nailed it
oh and it's an old tiny one oh it's
gonna be so good isn't gonna be the best
all right I'm gonna help her trail out
utility be using those skills all right
let's go Oh
so okay mr. Ceaser second one with the
warmth of levels I need to give this a
sweet-ass new paint job yeah get that
didn't it you think I could have like
some lower the suspension yeah I don't
know though I feel like because you want
the tow truck to function properly but I
also want a race transmission and a
turbo oh yeah you gotta have the turbo
in there I think we're good right I
think so you know okay and lights
machine on life oh just people should I
get a new one yeah no you got it just go
all right dude look at my wheels right i
will say i really like the blue on the
wheel yeah I doesn't see you put those
on there but I go to get that was worth
the extra time I'm glad I got that turbo
cuz this thing is sick all right I think
you got him I think oh yeah this is like
the end of one of the Fast and Furious
movies when they had to drive it out on
the city and slam that slingshot is this
no good taco truck situation over oh oh
that is a strike i want i just met one
was a freebie you think they're okay and
look there's the paramedics coming out
there we go be serious torque just
talked to call miss all the Giants mi
all right maybe that's a bad idea i
think that one might be a little too
much for you here's what we are gonna do
all right cooking on this guy whoa oh
wow he's a [ __ ] alone thank you were
home oh yeah oh you like Nazy oh wow
that escalated I got to get out of here
but his face up in a big way wow wow
that old boy oh wow oh [ __ ] I've ever
rough landing but ok oh ok here we go
here we go here we go here we go you're
all warmed up this time ok time to give
back to the community all right we're
gonna feed the homeless with my food
truck yeah oh yeah nailed it first time
this oh we got ourselves a food truck
you guys like food hey you guys check
out this food you jerks oh you guys like
taco taco exclusive I was there an
explosion blows the flavor what what was
explosive inside of this taco truck put
a grenade back there oh good night sweet
prince oh there's a man who's I sleep on
the ground so you need to turn around
and then you need to be have your back
to whatever you want to take the photo
upload to gallery oh no that fired
priming I got red whoa whoa Evan else oh
no oh no did they just he's riding the
fireman he's fine why is the term would
I buy through traffic what is your deal
fireman that one's for evidence that
one's pretty good nobody commits crimes
against fire men aside from me Oh what
what are these people real big old
pieces of [ __ ] come along trying to just
reach over here this is this guy BAM one
and done the firemen don't care good
whoa-oh-oh like a brotherhood of shitty
Escalade drivers oh yeah how he's moving
pack fortunately I did not travel very
far cuz I got real distracted real fan
good i think these men need help another
kind of help you're home free are you
sure about that uh-huh oh here's how I'm
gonna give back to the community with
this tractor that man I'm gonna die man
who was working the field did not
realize how close to death he had come
in that moment that tractor literally
saved his life yeah gonna bail for
starters
oh yeah then I yeah keep your way it
whoa totally blew that dude away what
the hell why didn't even do anything
what is happening they're not even after
you they're just trying to murder that
dude nice work that's one nice oh you
monkeys and out because you like baja
what you just chest bump the police
officer and they shot you on I was
giving him props I was saying that was
good work what you did just now give him
props apparently i was giving props to
that guy he'll be you're giving illegal
props i was given a decent problems come
on guy is terrified of you kill that
dude but there it is yep its back what
what do you think that explosion you can
kill dollars though i did get ten ten
dollars here we go that's not as nice as
my one yeah you gotta got a hostage
shoot i got a hostage situation I don't
know what I wanted to link them into the
wilderness this man is in his car you
know it's terrified careful yes
absolutely terrified and I'm just gonna
cutting rocket oh oh oh I give around
others double take double take oh no I
lost him free what is this I think
that's a mountain lion might have been
so the trick to sky falling and
surviving is that you always need to
collide with a vertical surface just
before you hit the ground that way you
only take the horizontal damage and not
the vertical damage there you go like so
Melissa the airport or maybe else's
mother
so I'm just gonna kind of pop it in
there just lop it there we go we're good
all I did was fully damaged my brain no
well you know you don't even know now I
do all right we got all right there's
there's some jets I see Jets oh you
don't guilt do you don't get killed all
right mash and grab smash-and-grabs next
you grab it so long for the runway yeah
he's right out of their ceremonial
gunfire are you going there's all the
people maybe I'm coming in too hot for
them to spawn whoa ready three two one
nine and a half bail out bail out here
comes the explosion and help high five
from milk nope wow that was a real dick
move look I street justice oh that was
some street justice you got street
justice good for that guy though yeah I
really took it to me real quick I gotta
finish what I started all right we're
good I would work well that is it for
see you later bye that is it for another
episode of the Shan method if you guys
have any suggestions for games that we
can play on upcoming episodes I would
love to hear them tweet me at s McInnis
oh where do you see right here and throw
any and all ideas my way doesn't we've
mainly focus on open world games here
but it doesn't have to be that genre
anything where we can kind of like bend
the rules and just goof around in Volvo
Trucks totra maybe high explosives or
maybe sky falling or sky falling always
good yeah all those are great ideas my
station was animal crossing yeah now
that I pig out on maybe not in the park
I falling in that game alright guys so
again Sean begins here Maxwell McGee
thank you for watching and we will see
you next tuesday at 11am pacific